- NOW FIRST,
LET ME JUST SAY
THAT I'M ENCOURAGED THAT SO MANY
OF YOU FROM THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
HAVE AGREED
TO MEET ME IN THIS WAY.
NOW, AS YOU KNOW,
I'VE TRIED VERY HARD
TO REACH ACROSS THE AISLE
AND GOVERN THIS COUNTRY
FROM THE MIDDLE.
- WELL...
ALL DUE RESPECT,
MR. PRESIDENT,
WE DISAGREE WITH YOU.
- WE THINK YOU SHOULD
RUN THE COUNTRY FROM...
NOT THE MIDDLE.
- WELL,
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE.
IF YOU WOULD, I'D JUST
APPRECIATE SOME FEEDBACK
ON SOME NEW IDEAS
AND DIRECTIONS FOR THIS COUNTRY.
FEEL FREE TO AGREE
OR DISAGREE.
WHATEVER YOU WANT.
- WE'RE GONNA DISAGREE.
[chuckling and murmuring]
- YEAH, DISAGREE.
- DISAGREE.
- [whispering]
DISAGREE.
- FIRST, I THINK
THE GOVERNMENT IS TOO BIG.
I THINK WE NEED
TO SHRINK THE SIZE
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SO THAT ALL DECISIONS
CAN BE MADE
AT THE STATE LEVEL.
- WE DISAGREE, MR. PRESIDENT.
- MM-HMM.
- YOU DRIVE
A HARD BARGAIN, YOU WIN.
[chuckling]
- THERE WE GO.
- BIG GOVERNMENT IT IS.
[classical music]
- ALL RIGHT, NEXT UP, THIS
HAS BEEN A HOT BUTTON ISSUE,
BUT I THINK WE CAN
SETTLE IT RIGHT HERE.
NO TAXES FOR RICH PEOPLE.
- WE COMPLETELY DISAGREE!
- ROUND TWO
GOES TO YOU GUYS.
[uncomfortable chuckling]
- OKAY.
- UH-HUH.
- MORE TAXES
FOR THE RICH.
- AHEM!
- WHAT THE [bleep]!
- WHAT IS HAPPENING TO US?
- MAN, I AM TAKING
A BEATING HERE, GUYS.
ALL RIGHT, LAST ISSUE.
IMMIGRATION.
NOW WE NEED
TO SECURE OUR BORDERS.
AND ANYBODY
WHO'S HERE ILLEGALLY
SHOULD BE HUNTED DOWN
AND DEPORTED.
- GSSK!
GAAK!
NNG!
WE DISAGREE!
AAH!
- DAMN!
NNGH!
[crying]
- WE ARE COUNTRY OF IMMIGRANTS!
NOOOOOO!
- WE NEED A CLEAR PATH
TO CITIZENSHIP
FOR ALL OF THOSE
WHO ARE ALREADY HERE!
AAH!
HELP ME!
[crying, screaming]
MMM! MMM!
- GREAT,
I LOVE YOUR IDEAS.
LASTLY, WE CANNOT
REGULATE FIREARMS.
- [muffled]
YES, WE CAN!
all: [chanting]
YES, WE CAN! YES, WE CAN!
YES, WE CAN!
[crying]
- ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
IF YOU GUYS SAY SO.
AND NOBODY BETTER
THROW ME A CIGARETTE.
AIN'T I A STINKER?